[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti io mi chiamo mi
chiamo sebastiano e oggi volevo parlarvi
della forma e della sostanza o meglio
volevo parlarvi della sostanza della
forma e lo faccio partendo da la frase
di un personaggio che tutti voi
conoscete che oscar wilde che diceva che
forse provocatoriamente che solo le
persone superficiali non giudicano
dell'apparenza oscar wilde forse voleva
dire che la forma è sostanza
e questo non è come dire un giudizio
morale è fondamentalmente un giudizio
estetico estetico nel senso più profondo
del termine nel senso platonico del
termine platone parlando dell'estetica
ci diceva che è un equilibrio tra l'arte
la forma e la scienza la sostanza e le
due le due dimensioni dell'estetica
fondamentalmente dal punto di vista di
platone avevano lo stesso valore
la scienza però aveva il compito di
tenere un pochino a bada l'arte per
evitare che che prendesse le pulsioni
delle passioni e quindi in qualche
misura la forma e la sostanza sono i due
lati della stessa medaglia della stessa
moneta come nel vecchio conio anche nei
nuovi coni in realtà i due lati del
della moneta sono diversi hanno diverse
sfaccettature diversi contenuti ma hanno
esattamente lo stesso valore e allora
io insegno marketing e
in realtà una delle cose che insegno ai
miei ragazzi e che noi scegliamo con gli
occhi
noi scegliamo con gli occhi il senso che
attiviamo prima di tutti gli altri
quando decidiamo di comprare di comprare
qualcosa e il senso della vista e non
solo scegliamo con gli occhi ma gli
occhi creano un pregiudizio rispetto ai
prodotti o alle marche che acquistiamo
un pregiudizio che può essere negativo e
positivo positivo e solo parzialmente
gli altri sensi il tatto l'olfatto
l'udito il gusto possono modificare
quello che noi abbiamo giudicato con gli
occhi noi giudichiamo con gli occhi e
potete
provarlo tutti i giorni anche voi
stasera si è tornati a casa provate a
fare un esperimento con le persone che
conoscete e che abitano di fianco a voi
provate a mettere due prodotti diversi
in due confezioni uguali e senza dire
nulla fate di assaggiare alle persone
che avete intorno a voi scoprirete
magicamente che loro le percepiranno
incredibilmente simili se non
esattamente le stesse provate viceversa
mettere due prodotti uguali in due
confezioni diverse e scoprirete
facendoli assaggiare senza dir nulla le
persone che conoscete che loro le
percepiranno significativamente diverse
allora questo è il potere della forma la
forma un grande potere e la sostanza
senza la sua forma perde un sacco di
cose perde per esempio la qualità la
qualità c'è
se c'è la forma in molti casi
perché questo formaggio che noi emiliani
visto che anche prima
abbiamo condiviso la nostra emilianità
amiamo tanto a questa forma
letteralmente questa forma che è una
forma dai 35 40 chili che ha una suo
design fondamentalmente ce l'ha per
mantenere per generare qualità perché
grazie a questa forma la maturazione del
prodotto avviene in modo omogeneo sia
all'interno che alla parte più esterna
del della forma attesa e grazie a questa
forma il formaggio si può specchiare in
modo radiale così come sono abituati a
specchiarmi a consumarlo noi tutti i
giorni quindi la forma e garanzia della
qualità del prodotto ma se la sostanza
senza la sua forma perde anche identità
fascino e quindi interesse sarebbe la
stessa cosa il prodotto che c'è in
questa confezione senza la sua
confezione non sarebbe la stessa cosa
non ci racconterebbe la sua storia la
sua magia la sua suggestione e la sua
come dire completezza non sarebbe la
stessa cosa fondamentalmente la sostanza
senza la sua forma perde anche
funzionalità cioè il senso per cui
esiste fondamentalmente quello che vi
faccio vedere in questa immagine è la
forma la stampa lo stampo di un famoso
biscotto che probabilmente tutti voi
avete usato qualche volta per fare un
dolce per esempio un tiramisù la sua
forma in realtà ci racconta come usarlo
quel biscotto perché quel biscotto
consente di accostare un biscotto
all'altro in modo tale che il mascarpone
che noi mettiamo per fare quel tiramisù
possa entrare tra i due biscotti e
rendere quel dolce un prodotto un po più
buono da mangiare fondamentalmente è
anche la forma concava che come dire
conferisce un senso di leggerezza questo
biscotto è un elemento diciamo di
funzionalità del biscotto stesso per
poter come dire potere e diciamo mettere
il mascarpone anche all'interno
all'interno di questa parte concava
steve jobs il creatore di prodotti
bellissimi che tutti noi riconosciamo
come delle icone di stile e di design
diceva che il design lui creatore di
prodotti bellissimi che il design non è
come una cosa appare è come una cosa
funziona
il design è come una cosa funziona e
quando lui pensò il suo più importante
prodotto che è in qualche modo l'ha reso
immortale nella mente di tutti noi il
primo smartphone creato dalla sua
azienda ai suoi progettisti disse una
cosa io voglio un telefono con un
bottone che possano usare i bambini di 5
anni che non sanno né leggere né
scrivere e le persone di 80 anni che non
hanno mai acceso un computer
questo è quello che voglio e questo fu
creato un telefono con un bottone che
poteva usare chiunque semplicissimo
bellissimo senza neanche il libretto di
istruzioni
l'ora il design è come una cosa funziona
la sostanza senza la sua forma perde
anche il ruolo e il senso è che vi
racconto di una storia meravigliosa
quello che vi faccio vedere in questa
immagine non è la confezione di un
prodotto
è prima di tutto un opera d'arte
un'opera d'arte creata negli anni trenta
da fortunato depero e oggi ancora uguale
a quasi cento anni di distanza
un'opera d'arte perché non solo perché
era bella esteticamente perché era
rivoluzionaria per la sua capacità di
avere un'identità riconoscibile ma
un'opera d'arte perché aveva un
significato sociale e culturale perché
questo prodotto veniva consumato nei più
bei bar del centro di milano dagli
aristocratici degli anni trenta e
quaranta che potevano permettersi di
andare a fare un aperitivo appunto in
piazza duomo ma erano pochi erano
pochissimi quelli che potevano farlo la
stragrande maggioranza non poteva
permetterlo e fortunato depero e
l'azienda che ha prodotto questo questo
questo prodotto che tutti voi conoscete
in realtà lo pensarono esattamente per
dare un messaggio sociale per dire
guarda tu non puoi andare nel centro di
milano a consumare quell aperitivo ma
poi comunque farlo a casa tua
riproducendo magicamente
diciamo un cono rovesciato il
momento aperitivo che non puoi non puoi
consumare diciamo in modo in modo
normale come tutti gli altri allora
questo è un grande messaggio dal punto
di vista culturale e dal punto di vista
sociale ma non solo quel prodotto fu
rivoluzionario e per questo è ancora più
che un'opera d'arte perché fu
probabilmente uno dei primi prodotti
sostenibili
non solo perché era di vetro un
materiale sostenibile ma perché la sua
forma a cono
consentiva all'azienda di non
trasportare aria negli spostamenti dei
prodotti da una parte all'altra perché
il prodotto veniva stoccato in cassette
con un cono verticale drit con un cono
rovesciato che si incastrava
perfettamente dall'altra parte
riempiendo completamente le scatole per
trasportare il prodotto quindi senza
trasportare aria ma trasportando solo
solo prodotto capite allora il senso
profondo nei prodotti è tutto un grande
inganno è tutto una grande macchinazione
degli uomini di marketing come si dice a
volte come me o delle grandi
multinazionali che vogliono
come dire
diciamo torturare o comunque a forzare e
le menti deboli dei consumatori per
convincerli a fare qualcosa che loro non
vogliono fare male o per rispondere a
questa domanda
ve ne faccio un'altra e vi chiedo chi è
secondo voi il anzi la più brava brand
manager del mondo il manager di
marketing o di branding che ha fatto le
cose più straordinarie nel mondo chi è
secondo voi ve lo dico io rispondo io
questa domanda il miglior brand manager
del mondo e la natura e la natura non ci
credete qual è il mestiere della forma
della confezione della forma qual è
l'obiettivo di una forma l'obiettivo
della forma fondamentalmente e fare
queste cose costruire un design un
colore un'identità un elemento di
riconoscibilità e un elemento di
memorabilità io devo ricordarmi di
quella forma nel tempo allora qual è la
forma più perfetta di questa per esempio
questa è una forma perfetta che ha fatto
la natura perché perché consente la
crescita e la maturazione del contenuto
che c'è dentro consente la raccolta e la
conservazione del contenuto che c'è
dentro e consente anche la protezione
l'identificazione la riconosco subito ha
un colore perfetto una forma perfetta e
il consumo del prodotto stesso perché io
posso consumarla tenendolo in mano loro
è una forma perfetta e il brand manager
di questa forma è la natura ma vi dirò
di più che noi oggi nelle ultime
settimane come dire leggiamo sui
giornali o vediamo in televisione un
grande dibattito sul tema delle
etichette nutrizionali no dell'europa
che ci vuole dire semaforo rosso
semaforo verde questo prodotto non lo
devi consumare perché fa male questo
prodotto al semaforo verde quindi lo
devi lo puoi consumare in grande
quantità noi noi italiani ci arrabbiamo
perché i nostri prodotti come dire
spesso al semaforo arancione o rosso
in realtà la natura alla logica dei
semafori c'era arrivata da sempre perché
non solo questa forma è perfetta per le
cose che vi ho raccontato ma è perfetta
perché ci dice anche quando è il momento
giusto di consumarlo no il suo colore ci
dice quando è il momento giusto per
consumare allora capite che la forma è
sostanza
allora per provare arrivare un po verso
le conclusioni del mio intervento volevo
lasciarvi con una piccola suggestione
che come dire mi è molto cara una
sintesi tra forma e sostanza una qui la
chiamo la golden set list cioè le
quattro cose che in qualche modo sono
garanzia che i prodotti e le marche
possano avere un futuro anche lungo io
la chiamo la regola dei good for delle
cose buone delle cose buone le quattro
cose buone la prima è che le cose che
possono avere un futuro che avranno un
futuro sono quelle buone per noi buone
perché ci fanno bene e perchè ci fanno
stare bene anche dal punto di vista
psicologico
il secondo good and good for planet non
esiste l'idea di un prodotto di una
marca che non porti con sé la
responsabilità di pensare che ciò che fa
bene a noi deve far bene anche al mondo
in cui noi viviamo good for community
perché noi sempre di più oggi per le
vicende che il mondo sta vivendo abbiamo
bisogno di una comunità e di un senso di
appartenenza e le marche i prodotti del
futuro devono capire questo senso
d'appartenenza e rispettarlo e da ultimo
ma non per importanza woodford pocket
perché chi è una cosa costi 10 centesimi
o 1.000 euro noi dobbiamo avere la
consapevolezza e la sensazione ma anche
la la realtà che questa abbia un valore
vero per noi e non un valore finto ma un
valore vero perché e vi lascio con la
frase con cui ho iniziato solo le
persone superficiali non giudicano
dell'apparenza grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]